All right cool all right. Hey guys. We're here. Let me get on to my
You go on to the Facebook account on my phone so I can tag everybody give me a minute
There we go hi to everyone I think we're good
Okay, that's gone through right on give me a second. Let me get out of this. I don't get
crazy notifications
Okay, all right. Hey guys, uh, we're in all right good deal the zoom is open
Yes, it's open change the setting
Yeah
All right, man, you guys got questions. Come on zoom type them in the chat here and we'll get going. Okay?
Okay
All right, uh, well I wait for some people to hop in i'm just I got some notifications from last night
Oh, hopefully those guys are
Okay are hopping on good deal
Who we got there? Oh, hey josh, how's it going?
Good. How are you doing? Jeff? Good, man. Good. Good. How can I help you with?
Yeah, I would love your help on looking at these ads that i've got running
for a
Friend and a client at the same time. It's in the windows niche
and
installation or cleaning
installation
Yeah
so I
Picked him up as a just to help out with his
ads
Originally before I even jumped in this program. So looking at what it would look like maybe now
I probably wouldn't have jumped into this specific niche
Thankfully, it's it's still um, he's fronting the ad spin
so i'm not trying to do a lead gen for him just trying to help run this i'm trying to make it more efficient and
Help him bring more leads in getting some clicks, but we're just not getting many phone calls or conversions
So i'm assuming that some of the words that i'm targeting and maybe even the landing page i've got are not
With the best for conversions. So okay
You should be able to share your screen, I think I changed that setting, okay
All right, can you see my screen? Yes
Okay, great
So here's what we're looking at as far as the ads go
To the ads account
Yes, now I can
How long has that been running for what's the start date on that start date was uh, january 28th, okay, so about a month
Okay, good deal
And fort worth is how many people again? It's it's a big city, right? Fort worth is about
900 000 or maybe a million
Big ass city to be running campaigns. Okay
All right. What's your like daily budget?
Daily budget is sitting at
Going here real quick
I believe it's about 32 a day
Hmm. What's cpc for window installation? I would imagine it's bigger. It's pretty
it's
Probably over ten dollars. I'd imagine it can range. Yeah, it's usually about anywhere from 25 to 30
Or to 50. It can be even more than that depending on the city
I'm not i'm targeting different pockets the rural radius bubbles around three different counties
Which is a lot of area to spread through but trying to make it a little bit more specific to these certain cities that I think
That you could try drum up some business in
Okay. Yeah, two dollars a day
Okay. Yeah, and if something's like 20 you're not even yeah, okay, that's that's a big issue already. Okay
um
We'll go get into that. Um
one thing about the radius since you said that it's just
just be aware that like
You know, even if you do like a three mile bubble or whatever
Like that line that you see in the map like that's not like that doesn't like cut on a street or something any
Any zip code that that touches it runs adds to that whole zip code
So if you're in a big metro area and you're touching other zip codes
That could be an extra 100 000 people or whatever lives in that area
So it's just something to be mindful of sometimes in the bigger areas when you want to be specific
You're better off putting zip codes or like whatever those little mini cities are
Type of thing. Okay
Okay, I can see that as already being a big piece of it
Yeah, okay
Would you like me to show you
Yeah, go ahead. I'm sorry. I didn't mean to sidetrack you but I just when you said those things
I was like, let's just jump right into that because I know I love it. I can almost tell you that's that's an issue already
Yeah, so if I click into here you can see some of the the the locations
Right to see you what where i'm looking at
As soon as it loads that is
It's always slow and it's always slow in your own life. So don't worry about it. Okay
When it comes to those radiuses I can change them
I was doing zip codes for a minute and then realized like I have to double down on this
But I mean even Arlington's a humongous city
So a radius in a certain part of Arlington is not going to be nearly as effective like to your point
So these are these giant metro areas
Dude i'm working on
And yeah, you're probably running your ads to a couple million people
So I just need to I need to make it smaller a lot smaller or more precise
Yeah, and I mean, you know, I don't again whatever the cpc is that you're seeing like
I I don't really there's a whole window installation is not something for what we're teaching
As people shop for it, right they don't just go come over
So if you're going to run ads for it, it's a little more complicated than getting
Just kind of what we teach
But I would tell like
Without even looking at numbers like I would tell your friend you want to give me six grand
I'll do it. You want to give me eight grand? I'll do it
Other than that, that's a month. If not, i'm out
Got it. So and I that's just I don't even know the numbers. I could just think that that's what it would take
And that would maybe give you like fifteen hundred dollars and money to pocket
Yeah, okay. So that that's just off the top of my head
but um
it's like I had a client that is wanting to
Expand into like commercial roofing jobs, which is a whole different beast than like roofing
and
And I was like, okay
Well, you know and they where they live is not close to a metro area
And i'm like, I can't rank your website from where you're at into this metro area
Unless you want to give me some offices for google business profiles
Um, and I said if you want to run ads like that sale it's all about the sales cycle with these ads so like
You talk to your buddy about what's your sales cycle like like when you get somebody how many touches does it take for him to convert?
Now imagine no one even knows who the hell he is, right? So now it's like
This is this is the type of sales cycle where because window replacement is expensive
It's typically not
Unless you just want to do glass replacement for broken windows. That's something that you can maybe do what we do for
Right, but if that's not what he's wanting to get he's probably wanting to do big jobs, right?
Um is yeah
Okay, so that sale cycle is going to take multiple touches. So what we're what we teach here isn't going to be
As helpful for him
You're going to have to look at
Social media branding ads with retargeting
Facebook pixels display ads with retargeting from google and google search ads that we that we run
And basically he needs to be branded
He's going to need if someone's looking for him or that type of service and they come across his ad
Or his facebook thing you have to build multiple ads that will touch that person probably seven eight nine times
Before maybe they even come visit your site and that's why I said right off the top of my head
I'd be telling the guy
Six to eight thousand dollars a month minimum if he's not interested. I'm not interested
Because it's not worth my time or frustration
Yeah, and that's what it's felt like
It's been more of a frustration for me because I want to help him get some of these things going
But our budget is too tiny for these areas. He wants to and to your point
Being able to really retarget everybody once they've seen something first to be known
Is not happening, you know, so
Yeah, that's like the commercial roofer like this. He wants to do these things and then i'm like, I don't even know
I haven't even looked into it
But i'm like probably anywhere between six and ten grand a month if you want to do it
And you know, he's like, oh that's a lot of money and i'm like, well, that's what those it's
That's not you know, someone's gonna drop like a couple hundred thousand dollars on a roof job
Like they're not just searching google and clicking a button
You know, there's a whole branding to it. There's a whole like social proof to it like
i'm it's the same thing that nick talks about it's like
why we don't recommend kitchen remodeling or home remodeling things like that because
That's not something that somebody calls for someone to come do something simple
And and windows could be that way too because well what type of window?
What do I I want to you know, maybe the wife wants to come look at it and see it in a store and
You know, how does it open? What latch is it all those things? So it's a sale cycle. That's not like
Hey, my water heater broke or hey, I want to get my backyard
some concrete in it or
You know like emergency hvac repair like it's not something that's like a quick easy sale cycle like I need help now
type of thing or
This is such a lower
Like it's such a low cost item that i'm not really worried about
Like shopping around for the best best person
right
Yeah, so I I know that when I talked with this this friend of mine he was saying that his
Average cost is anywhere from six to eight grand for the windows job, right?
So that's usually what he would pay or get paid to do the windows
So in my head, I thought oh, that's a great like, you know, it's high ticket
But it's not I had to get over 15 grand like nick teaches. So you how do I move forward?
How do I best delineate between those two and know that i'm not getting into an industry?
That's just gonna like take my my breakfast and run with it. Yeah
If you're not familiar with like uh, like I mean this happens i've i've done this a lot and I'm kicking myself
like trying to help friends out
but um
It's just kind of like just like if you don't understand the process like or what the niche is and you just need to ask if you
I get I look at it like this. I was like like I own a home
There's services that I need I kind of like think about
How would I find this person I might ask friends hey if you needed if I don't know i'll ask questions for like other people
um, or go on the chat groups and find like how do you do this or
You know, how would you find this person or whatever?
Um, and then sometimes it's the business owner. You just go. Okay. I hear you. I get it
Like what what's your typical sales cycles like like how does somebody find you?
How many times you have to talk to them like, you know, it's like that
We talk about qualifying them and you what's your close rate?
Like if I gave you 10 leads, how many can you think you'd close?
right
most people if I do 70 you're like bullshit, but if they're like
Yeah, I could probably close like, you know, four or five people. You're like, okay
a little more like that person might understand that there's a cycle to their business and
you know, not everyone's an amazing salesperson, but
It's those kind of questions. You just gotta you just gotta kind of qualify them better and more and understand like what?
Is there a sales cycle and then you got to think about what we're teaching and what we're trying to identify with
um
You know again, fort worth large ass area arlington large area
uh
You're running the just looking at that. I bet you're running that ad to like three million people
Nothing's working for 32 dollars a day at three million people
Yeah, like zero things are going to work for us on that. So you're going to get crappy clicks crappy leads
um
you have a pretty high impression count which
Could be possible, but I bet your display ads might be selected or google search partners. Maybe by mistake
That's that's something to think about
But again, just yeah, this is like, uh, this is something that's not really
What we would want to run here
Um, like I said, it's a multi-touch multi-branded
multifaceted different platforms retargeting
Website pixels like it's a more complicated
Basket that you're weaving the catch leads in
So if I if you were in my shoes
Would you go ahead and just make these ads like really specific to like one or two cities?
With those zip codes instead maybe in an area where the cpc is more in that line
That should be or would you just reach out to the owner and be like hey man
Like I just want you to know this is probably not going to be worth your time
Um
Yeah, I definitely would like get rid of the radiuses and target better spots
And see if you can make something work
But yeah, I would just not have high expectations for them
And I would also tell them you have the data to show you what cpc is
There's no reason to be at 32 dollars a day. That's not even one click
So you want to set yourself up for you know, how many clicks a day to win one click a day is going to do nothing
That's like having one customer walk into your door
If you were selling t-shirts
If you're at a store that you know sold clothing one person a day is not going to do it, right?
You need multiple people because not everyone's going to buy some are just browsing and leaving browsing and leaving but some people will buy
So you need a lot you need more people coming to you
If you look at it like a store you need to get more people to you and to do that with google ads you have to set
Up the appropriate daily budget and an appropriate monthly budget to allow you to even bring customers into the door
If you don't you're already just saying I don't want I don't want to make money here. I don't I don't want to have success here
So some of that's just being just looking at the numbers
And it's uncomfortable. I mean like this commercial this guy that wants to do commercial roofing
I know I know he's not going to but i'm not going to try to make it work for him for five bucks
Like you're out of your freaking school. I'm not doing that
I'm not going to put myself in that position make me look bad
Get friction with my friend or my client at all. I'm like, hey, no, this is what it's going to cost to do that
I don't want to like if you're not if you're not willing to invest that i'm not
Because now we're going to be in this spot where you have to like now go. Hey dude, this isn't working
and it's uncomfortable and it feels weird, but
That's just the nature of this like you just got to be
This is just maybe talk to more about a cell cycle
Maybe try to target a couple of those smaller like suburbs and just try to fish in there and make it work for him
But look at your numbers in your search volume and determine
What you think what you know a daily budget should be and a monthly budget
um, one of the things that i've talked about
before with people is like
This is like this isn't like a rule like that you can like you'll find on the internet
I'm sure there's people that have different opinions on it
But like for me when i'm not sure and i'm like, well, I don't know. What's the daily budget going to be?
What's the monthly budget what I like to do is I like to take
the search volume
From like what I find in rare keyword planner
the monthly search volume and I add that up and then
Um
I add that number up and then I divide and then I find like 75% of that
And and the goal and so the thought is that well, I want to try like like I said
I want to bring customers into my door to buy my t-shirt. I need to get a lot so
Out of a hundred people that walk by my store. I want to get like 70 75 of them in my store. Does that make sense?
So that's so that's where that number comes from and it's just a number
I just it just seems to work and then I look at my my uh,
My top of page my highest bid cpc and then I multiply those two numbers together
That should give me a monthly budget and then I divide that by 30
And there and there's your and there's your daily budget and if you set them up like that
That's an easy way you can you can dive in and tweak things and get rid of fort worth and you know
You can make that smaller
But like but you're always going to do it with data and a little more confidence and then by doing it that way
Even if the friend's like, oh, that's too expensive cool
Not my problem. That's not my problem. If you don't want to spend money to make money, that's not my problem
That's a you problem. Not me problem, right?
Hey jeff. Yeah, can you can you go through that formula again? My my laptop cut out when you were saying it. Nope
Just kidding. Thanks a lot
You being late you owe me one you're late. I know I was on the phone
Whatever multiple clients this morning are like i'm like I got it
Yeah, so I take the the total number of search volume
And I i find like 70 75 percent of that number
And then I take my top of page bid
Okay, I multiply those two numbers together that gives me what the monthly budget would be
And then divide that by 30 just to say average 30 days a month and that will give me a daily budget to shoot for
And then I could tweak it from there
Like he's gonna have a huge daily budget and monthly budget with that many people he's running ads to
So I can now go well, let me just work on
Decatur texas. Okay, that's gonna be this much. Let me just work on mineral wells, texas
That's gonna be this much like then I can like bring my I can maybe think make things work a little bit better for me
If i'm trying to like get my own clients and like, you know, get my own leads and sell them to somebody
It's it helps
You know that formula will help you find these smaller areas and set yourself up for success in them, too
So that way you don't go i'm gonna do a window installation business outside of fort worth
And you're like i'm spending like 50 a day and i'm getting nothing
And when you run the numbers, it's like you should be doing
290 a day and you're like, oh my god, i'm gonna go bankrupt doing that. So so that that formula is more for us
But because you're because you like you're putting your own money out there first trying to get a business owner
But like in your case, you're you're trying to help a you know, a friend who is a business owner
so I kind of use that same formula just to like
Just to even know where I need to have that conversation out because right every business owner
not everybody a lot of business owners are like
Especially if they haven't done digital advertising and or they've been burned or whatever it is like I just want to do this
And spend five dollars
Why can't you why can't you make me millions of dollars if I give you five dollars and you're like, yeah, bro
It doesn't it doesn't work that way
so if you use that data
It just gives you a place of authority and then if there's like a conflict in the conversation you could be like here
Pop on a video boom. This is what google's telling me
What do you what do you i'm not lying to you? Like you can kind of have a little bit
of authority and and um
Just kind of like more of that expertise that like i'm using data to drive this
I don't if you don't want to do it. That's cool, but
I'll find the next guy that wants to make money
But use the data to your advantage
It gives you more confidence to demand money from a guy at a certain amount that you might feel uncomfortable with
Because you're like i'm looking at data
This is what this is just what it's going to cost me in advertising dollars
I'm not even talking about what I want to put in my pocket, right?
So at least then when you speak you speak from a better position of authority
Or and you have a better expectation if this is you were doing this on your own
You can be like, okay. I'm gonna burn like 75 bucks a day this and that but it looks good low-hanging fruit
I'm gonna make some money
Okay, i'm it looks like i'm gonna spend say two grand a month
So I want to sell this deal for four thousand dollars or 35 whatever it is that you want to try to set
But now at least even if you're spending more money per day
You have a better expectation of like what you need to get for it to make it worth your while and that's big, too
Rather than like oh, can we just do a thousand dollars a day and then you're like I lost money
Right. So like by doing that you set yourself up
To decide if you want to go into a niche or not or an area or not
And then you also give yourself that that expertise and that authority to make a better decision
And to make sure that you know what to sell it for to make money and that's probably more important than
how much it's gonna cost and all that other stuff is like
you know, because there's places i've gone into where i'm like
Like this is gonna be expensive. But damn if I hit i'm gonna make like seven grand on this
You know, like I can make some really good money or I can get into a revenue deal with the guy
you know
so
Yeah, that's really helpful. And I think that that's the the way to go about it with the best metrics for success
You know, you're planning for
Success not just randomness. Yeah. Yeah, just use the data and it's new. I get it
Like you're not you just that's probably your biggest issue here. It's just it's not a high budget
You're running it to probably several million people
and and as a niche it's not a
It's not a it's not a like one and done type of service it's typically a multi-faceted multi-touch deal
Okay, yeah
That's helpful then I'll work on uh narrowing down the cities a little bit more and just having an honest conversation with him
Yeah, my numbers and then also look at the overall budget for that too
Um, and that'll give me to a good spot. Do you can I show you?
Um the site that i'm driving traffic to as well so you can kind of let me know
if you would add some components to it or
Uh, yeah. Yeah if you want
This is what it looks like right now not mobile
He is an interesting window contractor I was gonna say that's cool that you have that uh-huh. Yeah, you have your types of windows
We also do door upgrades but that's just not part of the ads right now
And then quote from the bottom
Yeah, I mean it seems like a simple landing page for people
Yeah
Great
Well, i'll go and stop sharing my screen if um, todd wants to jump in here with his questions, but thank you jeff
I appreciate your help. Yeah. No problem. Good luck
Thank you. All right. Yeah
Hey todd, how's it going? Good. Good. Hey, can I share my screen? Yeah, absolutely
Uh, oh you again
Let me see if I can find the right screen here we go
all right
And then todd before you get going let me because when i'm streaming sometimes things um
Things don't work on the desktop. Let me just make sure no one's leaving comments on the facebook thing
Just give me one quick second. I'm sorry. No worries
Just it doesn't uh, yeah
Yeah
Let's see here
All right, let's see. There he is. Okay. Yeah jason will you cover negative keywords again?
Jason you covered got my own feedback
um
Yeah, jason, just remind me i'll do that. I'll try to cover this. Okay. Sorry todd. Go ahead
No worries. So this is the uh, the site i'm
Been running ads to the last month and again, this is my first the first
With this group. Um, and then this was the thing that I posted
um, yeah, okay, so base
Basically, I think what i'm trying to find out is is volume
So that's what all this is. These are just screenshots of the volume for all these different sites that I have
Uh, okay. So those different sites didn't show up on that sheet. That's why I was like i'm not sure
Yeah, I didn't want to I didn't want to you're fine. No, no, you're totally fine. It was just like i'm not
Fully, I wasn't just what you showed was not making me fully understand what the data was. I was like, yeah
No, no worries. So this one line four. This is that avondale tree service
Um, that's yours
This is mine. Yeah, okay. And so so what i'm i'm
Again, I think I think my issue with this is I picked one of my sites that has really low
Not low but lower
Called volume. I mean mangos only shows 10
4 000 impressions
Um, and then the ad itself
Looks like this
And again, it's only been since
What yeah, you're you're just out of that first two week thing anyway, so that's not yeah, sometimes that's part of it too
Sure, the first week is always terrible
Second week, it can get better third fourth week. It should keep getting better if you make the right adjustments to it. So, okay
Okay, so i'm looking yeah looking at 16 clicks over the 384 impressions
So basically again, i'm I should just keep it. It just needs to season more it sounds like
Yeah, and like the first week it's like it could be just complete dog crap
That's why we're like to talk because like the first two days is policy then after that it goes to this learning phase and
It'll try to run your ads at a whole bunch of different things and it's testing it out and that's where you know
you need to go in and like
Maybe put things to you know
Go review your search terms and go things to the negative keywords and that's you
Helping google train what you want your ad to kind of focus on and then you can make improvements to headlines
Whatever it is that you want to do and then that's where that second week now is like a week of that
You kind of do the same thing and typically after two adjustments
Most you're you're kind of pointing in that right direction and then beyond that it's just fine tuning it really
Okay, um, so that's why I always say it's just the first two weeks are just kind of like
I always tell business owners like hey man, the first month is not going to be awesome
I'm just going to be straight with you
The first two weeks are completely out of my hands because that's just google doing google
um, and i'm going to do this and this and we'll start seeing things the third fourth week and
That almost always works and when that almost always works
I've established myself as authority and expert and then we're good. We're great sailing from there
Okay, okay
So then yeah
And then the other question I had is is it typical that because cpc when I first started was like 490 or something
It jumped up to 839
Um is i'm assuming that's kind of typical right that it fluctuates or yeah, especially in trees trees will have a wild swing
Yeah, and it's weird that you think like oh, it's the winter time and it gets more expensive in the winter time
And then it dips and then it gets more expensive again
Like late spring sometimes I think is when it gets it gets again
And because right now is the time
well, they pretty much should be finishing that up, but they should have been all of the
Major trimming and everything else they wanted to do during the winter to set the trees up for a good spring, right?
so
That's why some costs go way up in the winter
Yeah, because i'm i'm also I have this site over here. Um
So this one's local to me would be that's the towing woodbury tree care now mango shows a volume of 80
It's a little bit higher in cpc right now. And again, it's up here in minnesota. So we're just getting into
Well, you guys also have trees up there
Yeah a lot. In fact, yeah, it's like okay. Are you familiar with arizona like where avondale is?
I grew up in uh, yeah, I started planting a church in buckeye. Yeah, okay. So yeah, i'm from tempi
I'm from tempi. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So that's going to be an issue with arizona, right?
It's going to be residential people with their trees and
Yeah, so you're you're not going to have as many
People just by the fact that they just don't have
You know people don't typically have big ass shade trees out there, right?
Right, yeah
And so this one is like I said, it's local up here in minnesota and it's again mangles has it higher cpc is a little bit higher
but the volume
Should last last season. I didn't have any ads joining to it. It was just you know, it's number one
It's on page one of google
And I had a couple of
I had a couple of calls coming in monthly never was able to lock anybody down
So considering doing this for the season
Running some ads to get this one boosted. I have two business owners that said talk to me next year
Yeah for that for that site. So so so that page one rank that those are your sites ranking on page one
Yeah, yeah, like
Yep
Like all my towing sites are in the map pack and those are all sold already. So that's great. Good job, man
Yeah, I would say then like
One oh good the what go ahead
I was gonna say like for that avondale one like I would just really
If it's really that low search volume and you're on page one and you're ranking for big terms
Like I just keep going for the organic play there and I wouldn't waste my money
Personally, if i'm ranking one on like multiple keywords or in the map pack for things that to me would just be like
Well, i'm my stuff's already there. Why do I need to keep paying for it? Right?
Yes, this is me right here. Yeah, I would just maybe try to work on getting some more reviews to it
Yeah, but look at number three same thing
um, so I yeah, I would I I think you're
Yeah, that's what I that would that's why I would put my time and money into it
just to try to rank it for other keywords in the area and
Just it's either gonna get clicks or not
Yeah, so maybe that low search volume it's just gonna save you money
Yeah, that's that's where i'm at right now. So i'm i'm really leaning toward really kicking into that tree this this tree care
one
because that's that's uh
um
Hold on
I
Think i'm in map pack there too. Yeah, that's right here number one and organic. It's awesome. Yeah. Yeah
Yeah, you're not quite in the map pack there but you're number one that's pretty good
Yeah, pretty much all all my tree care ones are my towing for sure
They jump really quick into map pack
But yeah, so I would just like just try to get those things to rank in some more keywords
Try to get that gmb up
And I make for the one that has a search volume of 80
That's one where if I know i'm doing really well organically and I can get the map pack up
Maybe what I do is just be really selectful with what keywords I want to run my ad to maybe not be as broad
And maybe be a little more specific even including exact match keywords
And that way i'm really and and what I could be doing then is like buying more real estate on page one
So you'll see my ad you'll see my site or you'll see my google business profile and you're going to see my like
I just own three spots of what 12?
Yeah, 13 maybe depending on how they're displaying it. It's pretty damn good odds
That you'll get some clicks that way. So that's something that you can supplement really good seo with
Especially if you know there's value to it
Okay, yeah
Yeah, and that and that will help reduce your overall ad spend and make it work in a in a better way
for you
Right. Okay. So just just to recap probably
um
Folk get more reviews on the avondale tree service and then the other tree service one run a couple of ads
keyword specific
Mm-hmm
I think and I also i'm trying to get break into the concrete world, but uh,
I got to do more due diligence on that. So, okay
Yeah, yeah, thanks. Yeah. Yeah, no problem. Uh, yeah keep it out. You're doing great on the seo stuff
That's that's the long-term play right? Yep. So yeah, I think that's the long-term play
The ads thing is great to get it going fast and also to like when things are slow
You can supplement with ads and like again, it can just get you
You know like a nick talks about in the sales about you know, it's like just it's about monopoly, right?
The best way to the best chances of winning the game and monopoly is owning the most properties on the board
And yeah, that's exactly what I was just saying
You just you can really be specific about certain jobs that you want certain types of services that you want
You can run them on top of where you're already ranking number one for
Um, but you can use the ads and you can be very specific on the keywords that you select
Including just doing exact match and you're you could just be like
Okay, i'm not doing really good on like say commercial tree services and I want to do that
So i'm going to run ads just there and maybe i'll get a job here and there from it
Cool, yeah
Uh, or I want to boost tree removal
And so i'm going to run an ad for that for this month and let it sit on top of my organic rankings
And now I got three freaking shots at getting someone to click on my stuff
Yeah, that's pretty that's pretty dang cool
Okay
Thanks, man. Yeah, no problem. Great job
Uh, I think I saw Janelle next I see your hand up
Hi jack, hi, how you doing?
We're back
You're back. Yeah
Um, well, thanks. It's good to be on here again and I will try my best to keep it concise. Um
We uh have that it's a similar the same business owner. We were talking about before
So just to recap we had new work tree service three. We have california, right?
So because we already picked that um, and we have a paying business owner and he's working with us and all that
Working with us and all that. Um, but we got a much bigger budget this time from him is willing to pay more
um
We're not running ads on new work tree service. We created two other websites for him danville and castro valley location, which are near us
New work's the only one we've been able to get a gbp on or gmb on
Um having a lot of trouble with gmb's lately
I don't know if everyone else is experiencing this in the last three months, but it's been auto suspensions appeal denials like everything
um
So just haven't gotten one to go through in a while
So we are now running an ad to castro valley tree service to that site for him. It's one of the newer sites
um, and
I just have some questions about the campaign and i thought I was just saying like i'd love to see your um
Some of your keywords if you wouldn't mind sharing because the click through it. It's brand new
We just launched a week and a half ago and I know it takes a couple weeks
But um, can I share with you and show you my screen on what we're seeing?
Absolutely
All right
And then the other thing is I get a little lost because I I think I created too many mcc's and so it's
Kind of having a hard time figuring out which is which so i'm sure I did it wrong
And then it's telling me that one of my accounts needs to be verified, but I don't think it's the one that's running
Um this this ad
Um, it's got a different account number
Okay, so let me see if I can find it really quick so castro valley tree service
Gosh, sorry. It's gonna just do this whole thing. Um
And then we got like
It stopped running our ad two days ago and it said something like we we had reached the max
Threshold or something and it only charged us 18 dollars and 20 cents
Um, and I was having a hard time finding where to do the payment
Um, and we've set our max budget to fifty six dollars and sixty six fifty six sixty six a day
Um, and I was kind of in line with what google was recommending. It wasn't the high end and it wasn't the low end
It was like right there
um
So it's telling you that it was like limited by budget
It said something about my threshold had been exceeded
So I put through a ten dollar payment or 18 20 18 20 and it looks like it's back up, but it wasn't
Right, like i'm still let's see. Hold on. You might have put a cap on it. Maybe like some people put like a monthly budget on it
Okay, if I did I didn't know that I was setting that up and yeah, I mean may not have I just
Yeah, what you're saying i'm trying to I can't remember last time I even saw something like that. So like it's not
Yeah, it was a weird thing at the top and I was like, what is this name?
Uh, it wasn't a big balance. So it looked like so that was the day like shut off. We got nothing
and then
Um, it's picking back up and let's see you started
You started it that could have just been a click, uh, a glitch in the matrix, too
I've had like i've woken up to like alerts that like this got suspended and that and I go on and i'm like
It's all there. I don't know what the heck that was like i've had weird like I just call them glitches in the matrix sometimes
Okay
Um, so we have gotten one call yesterday for this ad
But obviously not expecting to see much and it does look like I didn't see it today, but it looks like it's picked up
Um yesterday, so we got 14 clicks. I'm not using a lot of keywords. Um
I tried doing some negative keywords our score on optimization
I tried doing some of your old stuff that I saw like where you could say skip and skip
Doesn't let you do that anymore. Like it actually wants me to do this stuff
Really? Yeah, it wants me to do callouts. It wants me to do that. I do that all the time
It sends them back to you, but I just get rid of them
So it wants me to do conversion tracking dads. Nope. Do not do that
I know you guys will you just hit dismiss just tell it to piss off. They'll cut it. They'll
They're always going to try to make money from you. Just hit this
Just hit it. Yep. Bye. Okay back. They'll bring it back in a week. Big deal. Bye. Okay. I didn't see the dismiss. Thank you
And then should I be doing site links on ads? Do you recommend those? Yeah, it helps add some more
Um real estate to the ad if you have a full page if you have a one pager, no
Yeah, we have a one pager. Yeah, yeah, then you're not going to be able to do it. So don't do it
Okay, and that was a question that I had about the ad we're just doing one campaign one ad group
But it's tree service. So I was wondering do you think we should do an ad group for tree removal an ad group for tree trimming an ad
Group for like the different keywords or just keep them all in one
Um, what's what's the population you're running this to?
140 oh, let's see castro valley. I can't
65 000
Okay, are you running a radius or just a casserole just castro valley right now?
But we got a call from union city yesterday, which is a neighboring city
okay, so
And this is right along the bay, right?
Yeah, we're in the bay area. Um, it's near oakland
Yeah, but uh, let's see. So there's like union city and castro valley
San lorenzo san liandro some of those other areas
Uh, wait, oh, that's actually oakland castro
No, it's next to oakland. It's next to oakland. Okay. Yeah, I think my sister used to live. Oh, yeah
No, no, my sister lived just north of that. Sorry. Okay. Yeah
Okay, so I would okay so
65 000 people that's fine. I I don't think you need to run different ad groups
If you're in a more populated area, yes
That's part of the reason why we say don't do california
Because you have to set up more of an expert ad
Yeah
Okay
Does the optimization optimization score do anything for your ad or is it just
It doesn't always have to stay at 100 but yeah the higher it is the better it is just
If you go like if you go to the left and hit recommendations, that's going to tell you
All the stuff they recommend at the top left dish
Okay, hold on top left column. Yeah, you'll see or it says overview recommendations and site reports. Yep
Yeah, it was like call outs and site links and yeah, so I think it's important
so call outs what they're trying to get you to do with not call outs but like
Setting the conversions like people that go to like ctas and all that
That is a guarantee. They are going to spend all of your money every day
They're going to do it. You if you want to do that, that's great. But like
Even if I set an ad up for seventy five dollars a day
um, I typically don't run seventy five dollars a day unless i've like
Massively misjudged it but if I do if I set it up to do the conversion
It it'll always run my seventy five dollars a day
So that's kind of I don't really recommend doing it for what we're doing
Yeah, so yeah, you can just go here. You can just dismiss it hit the three dots hit dismiss watch your ad score go up
Okay, cool. Um
Like any of the recommendations, yeah, i'll just say oh I can just do dismiss all
I'll do it later
Yeah, okay. It's going up. Okay. I'll play with that later. I'll just just dismiss everything
Um, do we want just to save you a step you see the three dots next to the 4.3?
Yeah, click that just dismiss all and then hit dismiss. There you go. One less click for you to do. Okay. Okay
Um now any of these recommendations that we should actually do
Um, no, okay
All right
and then
Can I just especially not if you don't have like a if you just want to if you're running to one page or no
When you start getting to adding a full website
adding site links and call outs can be
Helpful in the fact that your ad might take up more real estate on certain displays
And if they give you more real estate to display your ad that typically means one more person's ad isn't going to show
So there's a tactical advantage to it. Is it necessary? Absolutely not
If you want to go through the hassle of it, you're more than welcome to it's not a negative thing
but you don't do it with a one pager because you don't have the urls for it, but um,
It's more of a real estate game than it is about like getting more conversions
Yeah, and we'd probably have to create different landing pages for each keyword and we have them all on one right now. So
just simpler
um, we don't have a ton of
keywords, but I just put some of the top ones and I've
um
This is not the keywords I picked. I don't know. I had like only seven
and then
Overview will show me what people are searching right if I look down here
Top searches
um
And then keywords
So I did
I I haven't done the negative keywords in a while, but I did put how to diy
Free all that stuff some of the brand name tree services are like, you know the big business
Yeah, can you leave this here for a second? I'm gonna i'm gonna scroll on a second tangent
So for jason who asked this question earlier
When we're looking right here, you can see in the negative keyword list. You can see how some of them are exact match
Some of them are broad match. Um
I if I remember correctly, there's no phrase match. Um
Negative keywords nor do you want that?
And the difference is that when you go to your search terms and you see a search term like anr tree service anvil tree service
And you select it and you say send to the negative keyword list
That's that term goes over as an exact match
Versus here where she typed in diy do it yourself
For free how to
Those things will go in it. You can select broad match or exact match. So hopefully that answers your question jason. Okay
Sorry, thank you
While you're here, I just thought I didn't want to ignore his comment. So of course
Yeah, everyone has like a lot of the same questions and stuff. So yeah, okay, so that's good
So you've you've gone through your search terms. That's great. That's what you need to do
um
Yeah, I I do wonder
If um, let's see you have you see it's
Saying not eligible my campaign is paused
Uh-huh
okay, so okay where it says
Sorry where it says like uh add callouts to your account all that like get rid of that
That window or whatever you want to call it there, yeah, okay, so you're looking at all campaigns right now
So you had two campaigns you had one that's paused one. That's not okay
So if we want to yeah, that's all if you want to go to the one that's running just just uh, no
Don't do that. I don't want that one
It's fine. It's not doing anything. Just leave it there
I i'm not a big fan of deleting stuff on google ads. So just leave it just hit pause
It just stays so now what we want to do is we want to look at go back to your campaigns
Sorry, I didn't mean to freak you out. Okay. So yeah now just click the one that's open click that just click it
Now that'll take you to the next one. Now you can look at now look at the top
Keeps bringing that that damn window for you. Um, now you can see okay. So now notice how now you have that campaign
Yeah, okay. So now you can even you can select an ad group if you had multiple ad groups
Which which is fine. Now you can look at keywords
Uh, no problem. Todd. We'll see you later
Right here. You can look. Uh, yes, and now that should be under this ad group. See how
Yeah, see you at the top. Yeah. Okay. Now you shouldn't see that
that
Okay, is that helpful sometimes when you see stuff? That's weird
What I like to do is I look at the top where it says search keywords and it has that like that's that's
Like right there. See how you go above that. See how it says you all campaigns what campaign and what ad group?
Yeah, so if I if i'm ever looking at my I call it the spreadsheet section and i'm like
This doesn't make sense to me. I typically go up and go. Oh, I forgot to select that
Um, and the other place you can get in trouble is on like the top of the spreadsheet
Where the plus sign is and I call it the little martini glass you have the filters
Sometimes people don't realize they added a filter to it if you go down go down
Go down go down right right right there. See I have the little martini
So sometimes people do a filter and they forget and they're like I can't find this and this isn't looking and I go
Well, your filters are turned on so you have to turn those off and then the other common one is the date range
So just fyi, so if you ever find yourself or you're like what i'm looking at doesn't make sense
um, that's just a just an fyi for you just uh
Just check those things and typically that you'll be able to sort out what you're not seeing
Yeah, it typically like for some reason it always goes back to the last date
I looked at and then i'm like wait, why am I not? Oh, it's not current. So
Yeah, that's fine. You're good. Okay, so we got our keywords here. Okay, so here's something that's interesting
So you have a lot of impressions?
And a lot of clicks at really really really cheap cpc
My gut is that you have display network on and search partners on
I turned it off. But can we look maybe where I go for that?
Uh should be in your settings
For your campaign campaign settings
Sorry, tell me where to go just go to campaigns
You're gonna go to the settings just hover over it
Hover over the yep. See the little yep. Okay
I'm having a hard time finding places. I get lost. Okay. Yeah right there networks google search network search partners display an hour
Shoot, I thought it's okay. It's super easy to super easy to miss. So go ahead save
I did it on that other campaign
That was the other castor valley and then I couldn't find it when I went to create it the draft. So that's why I did this other one
Yeah
Okay, so that's gonna help
That's that could be your number one issue right now
Okay. Yeah, we had a really it was saying the cpc was really low
Yeah, that's that's because you're yeah, and that's because you're running display ads and search partner ads
Uh, okay
And then audiences we just did castor valley now that you know, it's 63,000 and our budget is 56 a day
We try doing your calculation the 75 percent time, you know all that. Yeah for the main keywords. Um
But we're just not getting a lot of data in castor valley or even big cities near us
Like a lot of stuff is there's no cpc
Uh for our keywords, so we did the best we could
So
Okay, yeah, no, I think you're so I think that's your biggest issue was that
Okay, it's just that it's not firing where you want it to fire
All right. So now that'll be changed so that that should help you out
A lot and todd is off. But I mean these are all I have for keywords
Yeah, if that's what you saw in the data then that's what you use
Okay
But I think right now it's just like you got 230 impressions like I doubt that many I doubt that's your monthly search volume at all
Yeah, it's like 10
on each word
so you're not going to get a lot of you're not going to get a lot of action in that city, but
You'll get action which is good and it's california. So you don't want to get into competitive areas
So just hang tight where you're at and now that you made that
I think that was the biggest factor was you're just accidentally left the display network and search partners on
Okay, and then that's why your clicks are probably crappy and you're like, I don't get it
I'm getting clicks, but no one's calling or they're they're just clicking display ads and stuff and those are typically robots at night
Okay, and then um
Do you think we were going to try and put a logo on the ad but it makes me do advertiser verification
How hard is that?
The advertiser verification process well if it forces you there's a well
Them trying to get a logo out of you is different than
Them forcing you to do advertiser verification. So I just dismiss it
If you but if you make up a logo for him, you can put a logo in there
I mean we have one
But I I didn't want to have to do the whole advertiser verification because it was asking me stuff and I was like
It says are you running this for your your reason?
Yeah, that's you that's getting you verified which is fine you're gonna have you'll have to go through that at some point
But let it tell you you have to do it by this date
Okay, like I have on the other on the other one
When you do that, do you say you're working as an agency or you are the business?
Um, i'm the agency so I always use it as like i'm an agency
Okay, yeah rather than the business because then it's like now you have to get paperwork from the business
Do all that stuff and that could get weird it's easier to say yeah, I run my I run a small digital marketing agency
Yeah, okay. Got it. And then last question for you is
Should we be so he has the business owner has his own website
His website is you know been around a while. It's not getting any it's not doing great in the rank and rent industry
But we're wondering if it would be better to run some run the ad to his website
It's been around a lot longer and create a landing page off of this
As opposed to running him to castro valley our our rank and rent site
Or our landing page that's on our rank and rent site, but hidden
That makes sense
um
I mean
Because we don't have a gmb yet on castor valley
Where is our landing page? Yeah, but that's that's gonna just be
That that's an seo thing. That's not really
An ad worry. Yeah, not really an ad worry about it. But yeah, I I wouldn't um
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can do either one but I mean I would keep my own assets
Okay, so run it to ours if we're running the ad to a landing page. Well, never mind. Just hang on. Um
We have a we have two tracking numbers. We have the you know, the organic going to our website and then we have the landing page
Um for the ad that has a different phone number. So we're tracking like what's coming from what?
And then yeah, okay
Because we'd have to build a landing page off of his page with a different phone number because this is actually going to him
Yes, he won't be okay
Um, hey matt if you're listening any other questions i'm just asking my husband. Is that it pretty good?
Okay, maybe he's not on uh
Okay, cool. So just try that for a while and maybe expand to a few more cities if we're not getting a lot
Yeah, be careful with that area
Yeah expensive just make sure before you even expand it. I would run every little city every zip code has its own
Due diligence just so you know what you're getting into
56 a day is really not a lot in california for
ads, you know
So, you know just just take that for whatever it's worth it
At the end of the day, there's not a lot of search volume in the city that you're finding which is fine
um
But the the other factor is that your ads weren't running to google search ads. They were running to other places
So it's kind of giving you a false sense of what's going on. So great. Okay. Yeah
Yeah, and oh now we're getting to the page bit. You're in united. No, you're in the united states. Okay. There we go
Yeah, so because I was just there was blank data
So when we tried to figure out what's an appropriate budget we just we could only do it for a couple few words
So we just assumed it was going to be that much for the other that's saying it's 140 000 people that that ads running to
Which is fine
Yeah to reach
Yeah, see we have nothing to go for for those common
Are you seeing ads like when you look there are you seeing people run ads in cash?
Yeah, okay
Yeah, there's tree trimming right there I saw
So yeah, I found like a couple so I went with this as the high of what 1469
And I think I just kind of did however many keywords six and I just was like, all right
Let's consider they're all around that amount and make sure
Was close. No, that's fine. And your search volume's so low that I wouldn't be worried about it. You can see fluctuations in the search volume
um
So yeah, i'm not that familiar with that city
So it could just be that maybe there's just not a lot of trees there
But I kind of think that area has a lot of trees, right?
There's a lot and the crazy thing is when I do it impressions is above three thousands
3000 but it's saying 10
That's search volume but your impressions we're going to
Display ads and search networks. That's that's a whole other beast. You just
They will span the shit out of the web the internet on with your stuff like you had stuff running ads on
Um, like on people's games
You know, they could run like a free game and it shows you an ad you had you your ads were showing there
to like take a kid playing like
Block blast or some I don't know gold digger game out whatever the hell the kids are playing
But like that's what your ads are running to in that area when you have display network and other stuff on
So that would affect what we saw in the forecast because we were under that campaign when we were searching in keyword planner
Oh, that's why in the budget was showing such a low cpc
And a high impression, oh, okay interesting we're like, why are these impressions so high it should only be like 1500
Let's see. It's you know, it's united states. Okay. All right united states again. Yep
Seven point two thousand that makes no sense
Because newark, which is a bigger city used to be like around fifteen to two thousand
So, I don't know that's funky
Uh forecasting Brian. Oh, okay. No, that's fine. Uh, no you bring that back what you're doing
I know go back to where you were. I'll I'll show you something that's let's try to look at something differently there
All right, so see where it says match type for a keyword it says all keywords maximize clicks and then
Match type. Okay. Now change that
now do phrase
Now hit apply
Let's see if that changes
Okay, so let's see if that changes
Okay, now change that now do phrase
Now hit apply let's see if that changes
Went down a bit and look at what the what's the average daily budget
56 66 and what does that say it is 57. Yes, that's 57, which is what you have. So you're you're right there
Okay, it's just a lot of impressions
More than I expect to see for those this city
Yes
Yeah, but this is where like, you know in the past people, you know
Well, you know simrush shows this mangle shows that keyword planner shows this, you know
rare is really good because rare brings up rare will bring up your
Like google keyword data, right or google keyword planner data. So it's been really good to use
Yeah, but like that's why I tell people like you can even see mistakes inside google planner where like
One thing says something totally different than the other thing. So like none of this is perfect
Right. We just whatever data we have we just try to make the best decisions on it
But even here you can see that there's just weird differences with them
Yeah, just a lot higher than we used to see for even newark, but maybe the season two and the time frame
It's looking out for the forecast
Yeah, it knows it's going to get busier right now
Yeah spring
Yep. Yeah. Yep. Okay. All right cool. And then I see a more accurate cpc
17 15 13 dollars. It was low. It was like a dollar and we're like, yes, this is amazing
Yeah, no, that was just brought and that's because of the broad match thing
Oh, okay. Never like watch if you like now do exact match watch it drop even more
Yeah
See that
Okay, okay. All right
Okay, i've never even seen this is this the new feature or this has always been there. It's always been there
Oh my gosh, we just don't really teach doing the forecast thing. I think you guys get that from shiv's group. Yep
We do. Yeah. Yeah
Yep. Okay. Cool. Thank you so much. That was very
as usual
Awesome. That was helpful. Okay. All right. Take care
Um josh, I see you have a couple questions, but let me get to chris because he's been waiting patiently chris. What's up, man?
Thank you for being patient waiting
Is he there chris if you're there you're muted
Yes, no, no, yes, okay
all right, um
All right. Oh josh you had some questions. Let me see
Uh digital ad doi how to for yes, you did that manually
Okay, is that something you guys recommend? I haven't made it through all the ad things yet
It's not something that we like teach that you have to do but like it's something i've i've gone over with people like
these are some changes you should make and do but it's
it's uh
Um
There's some negative keywords that you'll just understand you just add like free cheap
do it yourself
you know this but there's like there's some areas that like
like
um
Let me say like like how much would uh, like how much would it cost to have my tree? Yeah
okay, so like I would say that um
like for me
Like in one area that might work for me where maybe I do like like with janelle like she doesn't have a lot of
Search volume
So maybe allowing that question is not a bad thing because it maybe gets my site one more rep
But if I was running that ad in a larger city
I maybe don't want to have I don't want to spend nine dollars for someone to ask the question about how much something costs
so I don't really teach it as you have to do it because
People are running ads in towns of 30 000 people and like you're doing it for 4 million people, right?
So like it so it's gonna be different like it'll be different. So I try to not
Like this is how it has to be done. It's more of like guidelines
You could do this if it makes sense for you
But there's small small population areas where like I don't mind if people call because there's not a lot of not a lot of search volume
There's not a lot of competition
So if my business owner is getting people on the phone
Calling and asking them questions or sending in a form asking questions. That's one more person that they get to try to sell to
If I get enough if I get enough of them and i'm like they're just kicking the tires and not converting
I'll get rid of it. But yeah, so
Because I see a lot of it not a straight answer but like that's why yeah that checks out
It's a lot of in my search terms section. It's a lot of like how much do windows cost?
How much to replace the window how much this or price this so I can see if it was a strategic way to
how get more views that's a that's okay, but
It's a lot of variations of those
Yeah, and where you're running your ads out like this would be like
like
Because you're running it to like a super major metro area millions of people
Um, I would maybe talk to my business owner and go hey man, i'm seeing like this is a lower cost item
Let's build you a landing page
Let's build a sales funnel where we start collecting people's info and bring them through like a lead form type of thing
To get a higher quality lead that's asking questions about how much something costs
Got it. That's the thought right now all of a sudden
Maybe that's a value now becomes maybe in a large area. It's an easy thing to break through the noise
Someone's like well how much would it cost? Oh, you know, thanks for clicking our ad
Like let's get some let's give you a good quote. How big's your house?
How many windows you have how many are you interested in this or this and all of a sudden you're just bringing them through
And if that person's serious, they're going to click through you may give them a freaking quote right there
over the computer
And they're like, okay
then now they have a range and now you're like maybe before you give them that hey give us your phone number or an email and
We'll send you a quote right now
Boom, and you set up a bot that sends an email and a text and it sends your business owner or something
But that's like super advanced
That's why we don't teach metro area stay away from that until you like understand that stuff
Some people will get that and be able to do that. But like again, that's like I said earlier
What would I tell your friend?
How much I would run it's going to be thousands of dollars a month. I'm gonna want from that guy, but that's why
Those are the things that we'll do to help them convert. Yeah
That's very helpful. Yeah, no problem
And cool. All right, chris. Are you there?
Give me a chance to get back on let me see here she google sheet by the way
Oh, yeah, that was pretty cool. Huh laura
Uh, jason, I think we answered your question on keywords, I hope
um
Cool. All right
Let me see no chris. All right, josh, you have any other questions at all? I do just one more
Phrase match so I saw in the training that you teach to use the phrase match as
Or keywords. Do you get into exact match as well?
Oh, yeah. Yeah, there's nothing wrong with using exact match. It's just that
when you're
When you're running to the smaller cities and towns we're not typically running against like a bunch of ad experts
so
You don't really need to have the variation. I will I do tell people like if you're going to do like
Tree trimming near me
I would make that an exact match because
Even though the phrase match tree trimming will cut will
May land land an ad for that. There's a competitive
advantage
Maybe a speed advantage to having
A certain search term as an exact match
Might fire like a millisecond less than a blink of an eye faster than something that's on a phrase match
But again, we're talking about being in super competitive areas
And then also a lot of students like I we have people that are very very new
And they're like, I don't know anything about they're like still learning about keywords
And it's a little different like that's why if you guys have seen francesca coming on on on fridays to like talk about like
Because there's a difference between
so
You know taking a step back the long-term play is seo
The short-term thing is you're going to use ads put your foot in the door and start making money and get business owners now
Which is way better and faster than building ranking waiting and then go crap. I made a mistake
There's six months down. I just wasted six months on this website, right?
Or there's nobody in this area that wants to do it or their search volume's really bad or whatever it might be
With the ads you're getting that yes or no so fast that it's worth the extra couple hundred dollars
Than it is to be like you either learn a mistake really fast
You learn that this area sucks really fast
uh, and it could just be like I mean there's a lot of places that i've gone to that i'm like
on paper it checks out
and i've done this in the past where I I learned first to like build and rank and then rent it out and
I would get like
All the numbers are here my ads this I are like my my website's here all this stuff
I cannot get a business owner at all and take my leads because they're so fat and happy
And so like nobody's like why why would I why would I uh pay you i'm i'm booked out 18 months in advance
And then you find out that like shit. There's just not a lot of contractors in this area
Or there's they have so much work that they're not worried about even they're
Works waiting on them, right people are waiting on them. And so then you go. Oh shit. Okay, so
You know making that mistake on an seo thing
Is very frustrating because I have several sites that rank really well and still give occasional lead here and there
Like
I couldn't give it away. I can't give it away to people
I've I have one where I had a guy that was driving four hours for certain jobs because they were that valuable
I mean we're talking like
300 000 jobs the guy's like yeah, i'll do that. I'm like, okay
But it's like he's not going to take every lead, you know
So it's just things like that. We're like i'm like, this is ridiculous. So
By by doing nick's method, I would have done that first there. I would have test built a one pager
Tested it out gotten some leads. I would have found that answer very fast and been like, okay
Maybe this isn't hey, I don't want to spend my time and money here
You know, you know, maybe i'll put it on the back burner come back to it in six months. Does that make sense?
So it does yeah, it's very helpful
Yeah, so that's why i'm just doing that to try to help you guys
Understand the due diligence part, but then because when the when the program was first created
We were using smart campaigns which were actually smart
Which actually understood your broad match keywords and your website and understood that like
Who you were and what you were trying to do and it pointed you in that direction
So it was really easy and fast, but that's gone. So now we're stuck in expert world
Where there's no medium world in the google ad space. So like we're trying to teach you like beginner
Expert so like we're actually trying to teach you the medium level because that's who your competition is where the cities that we recommend
That's really helpful and I appreciate you guys taking that approach. It's it's gonna pay off
It does it does there's a lot of success stories here. I mean, there's people
I mean, they're right. I mean they're passing they've passed me up and what I make so it's pretty awesome to see that
You see people doing that. So
Yeah
Awesome. Well, I really appreciate you jumping on and helping me out with some of these i'm gonna have more questions for you
So i'll be sliding in your dms and then wait for the next live chat room. Um, just want to say thank you so much
Yeah, no problem. Like I said, we'll be here. I try to do it once once a week as my schedule permits
So otherwise, that's it
Cool. All right. Um, I think that's it. Let me see Janelle. Do you have any other questions?
I think she's gone. Okay, cool. All right, man. We'll see you guys later. Have a good one
You